yeah go on you [__] but yet which shows
you they are looking for any excuse
attack Muslims and that's exactly what
they are doing and planning on doing
further just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends the da table in Liverpool was
attacked you saw what they done here's
the footage brothers and watch for
yourself how these scumbags what the
protest are pertaining to what happened
of those innocent young girls yes
nothing to do with Islam nothing to do
with Muslims nothing do with anything
but yet which shows you they are looking
for any excuse to attack Muslims and
that's exactly what they are doing and
planning on doing further this is the
clip of what happened at
Liverpool
[Music]
on so guys you see there how the da
table was attacked now brother and
sisters alhamdulillah I want to use this
opportunity inah to ask and tell
everyone all the Dow Brothers around the
country inallah to carry on the da and
set up more da tables okay now brothers
and sisters us at Salam we've got two da
tables one at Speakers Corner and one at
L Square aldah yeah there are brothers
who come there to film there are some
brothers who are D who are dedicating
their time and effort to come there and
we want to raise funds for that insh
okay as you guys know we have our Salah
plus project which has got the funds
alhamdulillah and it's doing amazing
work with the guide of prayer mats but
we need funds brother and sisters to
raise to keep the operations going in
leer Square in ler Square brother and
sisters W the amount of Shas that come
Subhan Allah brother and sisters is is
unimaginable if you want to do a
something proactive Subhan Allah
something constructive something good
brothers and sisters is that after this
hateful attack not only support those
Brothers but also please support our
Lester uh da table brother and sisters
we are there every Friday from about
5:00 p.m. to midnight alhamdulillah and
we give da and these cost will go
towards who the cameramen the editing
team and also a couple of Dies who come
there we financially try to help them in
okay I am a trusty I do not get a penny
just want to make that clear so I want
to support those who are on the ground
doing amazing work some of them like I
said before not that they ask Subhan
Allah but we want to inshah use these
funds to carry the da table at leester
Square every Friday you can come there
get your guided pray M come and speak to
us about Islam inshah the link is there
please brother and sisters donate
whatever you can and for all the
brothers around the UK Carry On Your da
do not stop in brother and sisters and
this is even a message from that's all I
wanted to share